hi I'm a light mode user yes I'm outing
myself I like the brightness in my life
Joey I like the light okay I go towards
the light I'm a [ __ ] moth okay
do you know the word haughty
horny haughty horsies
and you slang no this isn't an actual
word this is like is this like shouty
but without the s
we've never heard the word horsey does
anyone in the office know the word like
h-a-u-t-y or h-a-w-t-y explain what
haughty means
yes I love this world so dieters
he's literally the opposite of haughty
it's like kind of pretentious sounding
it's like oh God what does aloof mean
yeah I was gonna ask yeah I was stuck up
it's a pretentious Oh I thought a Loof
was like like not thinking about
anything like this is the best thing
about English there's an exact way of
describing the exact way of an [ __ ]
someone is there's like any shade of
[ __ ] the English language has a way
of being able to describe the perfect
level of like snobbery or dickishness of
someone what's what's the two words on
the two ends of the spectrum I don't
know it's just every kind of word you
want to it's like we have like 10 20
different ways of describing that
someone is a posh [ __ ] right it go it
goes from the Spectrum for me is
anywhere between oh he's a little rude
to oh he's a [ __ ]
that's the Australian one that's the
Australian Spectrum so it's always a
little bruising like that the reason
why I found this out is because I
um I got an audition yeah I guess I
guess we have no don't start with me
seeing the Sea World Cup
just put that blur that move down the
reason why I bring this out yeah and to
start the episode with this because I
didn't audition not too long ago
um it's the first time ever happened to
me actually is that uh that you became
pretentious no no I've always been there
um
sure so
um I I was they sent me this agency a
production whatever sent me a audition
sheet yeah I get this a lot and it's
it's whatever they like hey can you
register for a thing and this one looked
really good so they were like hey we
want you to read for this character and
I open it up and I had this thing that
happened that it's funny enough because
when we met with uh Jay Michael Tatum in
LA and Brandon yeah Michael was telling
us about a time where he had to read and
the reference was himself yeah they
wanted to sound like him yeah I thought
that's so [ __ ] cool that's never
gonna happen to me anything happened to
me and I was the reference
did they ask did you get the part so
hold on so but the thing was is that I
didn't never seen this word and they
were like sound like Sea Dog this this
clip it was me yeah I'm like cool cool
and that said it sound like this but
less haughty and I was like what does
that mean so so what's so what is the so
what is the definition of haughty you
know yeah is it h-a-u-t-y or is it
h-a-w-t-y uh
I thought it was like h-a-w-t-y okay
[ __ ] English right English language
I'll play the pronunciation for you yes
[Music]
so it means arrogantly Superior or
disdainful which honestly honestly
that's uh very very accurate are you
gonna add that to your Twitter bio yeah
haughty haughty YouTubers
[Music]
he's Mr haughty I'm waiting for the next
wacky weekend so yeah next to horty
Connor right here I had this exact same
thing as you guys where I I you know I
opened up the clip and I recognize what
it's from yeah but I don't say too much
because I I didn't sign an idea anything
but I was trying to you know good
practice
um yeah uh is it this but hot but less
haughty and I thought what the [ __ ] does
haughty mean so I Google it and I'm like
am I am I to be offended or
no I think they described you in the
perfect world
at least they at least at least they
kind of you know so served it up nicely
in a box so basically they said sound
like Sea Dog VA but take but take the
corner out of it yeah
just be less haughty you don't get a
voice like this and not sound like that
that's what happens like you don't like
I'm sorry so I I you got the whole
personality behind it right at least you
know at least you got to give them
credit that they at least you know open
up a thesaurus for this they weren't
direct about it they weren't like oh
yeah it would sound like this but less
[ __ ] pretentious and arrogant you
know like I don't know what I mean about
it that would be the most intricate way
of insulting me start your own like uh
project cast a thing and then send out
auditions to everyone you [ __ ] hate
and then just link them as the reference
you sound like Joe but less of a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
they were really nice I auditioned for
the thing and I did I guess what you got
the park
wait wait wait wait they wanted me to
sound like Sea Dog VA you must be less
haughty but less less 40 and uh can you
just like change your voice to that yeah
can you can you do it can you do it
right now
I'm gonna I'm gonna hear your voice in
this thing that you're just for and I'd
be like we could have had that I'm like
where's that called where's that guy I
want that guy oh my God this sounds like
an amazing corner I would say it's it's
it's the voice that I would do uh if I
was an [ __ ] but 20 nicer 20 night
twenty percent nice there's still that
level of like snobberiness yeah
uh that's so definitely that's the last
40 I suppose yeah so I did get the role
I've read for for the part I I've done
all my recording for it's a lot of fun
um so hopefully that'll come soon I'll
tell you guys when it is so you've got
to play yourself but nicer more I guess
I wonder because I I got a few things
that are coming out in the future I
wonder if people will be able to figure
out which one it is which one is the
nicest I mean when I when I had to voice
my own character in no straight roads I
think I had the opposite I was like play
as yourself but more haughty is that
possible for you yeah
I've literally called musical.ly just
like you can't get anything I'm in real
life
I mean Joey in real life I'm a music
hipster I would like to comment on your
new lovely glasses that you seem to have
procured thank you
I was going to say are you going through
your uh like art director phase like
what's the glasses also with glasses Joy
I don't know I just now that now that
I'm uh an owner of a brand I figured I
should probably start looking the part
just to have just funny LinkedIn
conversations people oh yeah we've seen
the [ __ ] they they do on LinkedIn you
see that one more clip where the guy
fired like a thousand people on zoom and
then yeah I saw that one oh yeah yeah
like crying like he gave a [ __ ] yeah and
it was like a one-way Zoom call as well
nobody could take part like it wasn't
even a zoom call it was a live stream
yeah we've done it on Twitch you know
what I mean the man literally pulled up
that that you know that that the meme
video everyone uses in in meme edits of
the guy crying yeah yeah that one he's
like the guy watched that video before
we went in and try to emulate that it
was so bad wait was this the one where
he phoned up half of like he opened up
with a speech about how he has to let go
of half the company yeah I was [ __ ]
hot that was so [ __ ] was that
something was that a different live
stream or was uh
yeah there's there's so many there's
been way too many Zoom firing for me to
keep up with nowadays holy [ __ ] I think
the one I'm thinking of was there was a
clip
[Music]
and uh yeah and he said he's taking time
off because apparently it got to him oh
oh he's got to him this is after the
whole controversy happened right with
like the company or whatever no no no no
no oh this before that no this is way
after but I was doing pretty good now oh
really he should consider signing up to
better help that's what the meme was so
I wonder if he gave free subscriptions
to his uh himself I should find 900
people and be like guys I need time for
myself yeah it's like what you know
because like I always thought you know I
think and I think everyone can relate
but like when you hear the title CEO
you're just like oh oh that sounds
really fancy but then when you actually
become a CEO you're just like I don't
like that title I mean I thought every
CEO says you're fitting into your Roblox
guys I'm not like other CEOs no but
that's exactly what happened when I
became a CEO I was like I kind of had
hate this word now I don't like it guys
I don't want to be I don't want to be
someone of you guys okay I'm one of you
guys it just sounds gross all of a
sudden
meanwhile puts on the glasses and by the
way have a CEO yeah by the way see you
all right could you tell I got my
business I got my business cards right
here got my business credit card it's
all sorted don't worry no but yeah
you're looking you're looking very good
thank you you should try it are these
like I wear fake glasses are these fake
glasses though fake glasses yeah I've
worn them sometimes yeah
Harry Potter
so this is a fashion statement of course
it's for making a fascist statement my
my eye says 2020. excuse me it's
literally a fashion statement my
eyesight is not your fashion Joey
I'm preparing myself for when my
eyesight I wasn't born with short
sightedness just so you can wear it I I
have some fake glasses at home that I've
won many times yeah that's good on you
bad bad eyesight isn't just something
that you can take on and off Joey you
have to live with it okay I can't
believe you do me like this Joey
you can't see anyways
no I've just I've just gotten used to
wearing like a lifestyle of contactless
because I'm I'm preparing myself because
I know for a fact when my eyesight turns
to [ __ ] at old age I'll be too much of a
[ __ ] to try and put contacts yeah
because I can't my eyes are too
sensitive I can't do it do you know do
you know one weird life hack I found I
find out like be rich
aside from Bee Ridge Lasik so I saw the
scene in an anime where when one
character has like short-sightedness and
like if you make like oh [ __ ] they fixed
it with the pinhole thing right and I'm
like what [ __ ] [ __ ] is this and I
actually memeed it in one of my videos
yeah and then then the comments are just
like no it actually works it actually
works trust me trust me and I'm like
okay what is it so what what you do
right is you just make a pinhole with uh
you make a pinhole basically a pinhole
with like your hand or something and you
look through it and then you're meant to
be able to focus even if you have like
short-sightedness I was like this is
absolute [ __ ] and then I tried it
and then it worked I was like what Oh I
thought you brought that up and it was
[ __ ] no I I want I thought it was I
thought it was [ __ ] so what you're
suggesting is that people have bad
eyesight should wear glasses where the
glasses like this big
tiny ones
the H uh 30 H3 the what's that band
called uh 303 or three they should wear
those glasses
I don't know what the [ __ ] science is
it's like insane but I'm like why like
something about my eyes is broken if all
I need to do is do this and granted I
can only read like because how I tested
it out was I was like normally I cannot
read subtitles at all if I'm watching on
TV that's absolutely impossible for me
but like do this look at it through a
pinhole and suddenly I can see like one
word at a time I can only see one word
at a time but for some reason it works I
I have no idea I have no idea what it's
basically the thing you know in school
when you were learning how to read and
you use the rule yeah
it's just that but now it's like one
word it's just one word at a time yeah I
I have no idea why this life hack Works
found out about it somehow it's not
[ __ ] science explains science please
it's like wait yeah which anime did you
see it in uh it was like an isakai
Pharmacy I mean of course of course it
was it was the east side pharmacy anime
I wasn't mentioning Dr Stone as well
okay yeah I don't know I don't know why
that works like body stupid or something
like that
brain dumb yeah wait so how bad is your
eyesight my eyesight's pretty bad it's
not like awful awful bad but when did it
start getting bad
I don't think you told the story I I
don't know if I've told the story uh
maybe I have but I've I've started
getting bad when I was like a teenager
not a teenager like a kid oh [ __ ] like a
kid so like right when I was like
Primary School yeah Primary School
um and I'm gonna call out my mum for a
second here because she's gonna stick
this too yeah she's gonna see this but
she can confirm that this happened
because back in the day
um I was like sitting really close to
the TV and my mum was just like don't
sit close to the TV your eyesight is
going to get worse
and so I was like I was like but mum I
can't really see the TV right now she's
just like it's because you're playing
too many video games yeah just just try
harder just look harder okay but just
keep your eyesight just keep your
eyesight and check okay and then I do
this
basically it was like the most Asian
like it was like the most Asian advice
you could ever think of it was just like
just just look harder
she was like son just uh just get good
just get a good eyesight and it was only
like until like I was like it was like
three years down the line when we just
had this [ __ ] realization of oh maybe
I'm just short-sighted so wait was it
because I've always been interested so
was it like when you when your eyesight
goes bad when you're a child right yeah
is it like a gradual thing over like
many years to the point where Suddenly
It's like the the change is so slow that
you don't notice the change happening
until it's too late or is it literally
like you wake up one more and you're
like I can't [ __ ] see
um honestly I my eyesight was bad to the
point where look it's it's always been
bad to the point where I don't remember
ever having good eyesight I don't think
I've ever had a perfect eyesight I've
just like my some of my earliest
memories are having something on TV and
just me going ah I need to sit this I
need to sit like this close to the TV in
order to see the TV like I've never I've
never sat on the couch and be like okay
I can see the TV TV I've always had to
sound like near the TV
um obviously that was you know what made
my back my eyes like that
in the first place uh according to Asian
parents but uh no like I've I've always
had bad eyesight and it was only when I
was like seven ish that I did I got my
first glasses and I remember the first
time putting on glasses and I was like
holy [ __ ] this is a life hack
what is this people's people's is
normally yeah what well I think I saw
that it was a long time ago there was
this like our artist this digital artist
that like Drew watercolor paintings of
what it would what the world looks like
to people who have bad eyesight and I
and like what looking at that painting
as someone with normal eyesight I was
just like this is giving me a headache
yeah I'm like I'm like damn y'all live
like this
it's like holy [ __ ] so that's I think
it's after that that I saw that that
made me go like okay I need to like
really take care of my eyesight so like
now whenever I'm like sitting in front
of a computer or a TV or whatever or if
even if I'm like staring at my phone for
a long time I always wear my blue light
glasses because I've always had really
really sensitive eyes I don't know why
because like can you guys open your eyes
in a pool yes I can't do it because like
the moment I open my eyes I can
physically feel my eyes burning oh yeah
no I can yeah everyone's does yeah
but mine Burns
mine Burns
[Applause]
in Australia right because it's like you
know Summers get really hot and in
Australia you always have that one
friend who has a pool in their house
right so you go you go swim in their
pool and then you know there's that
moment usually in like early like middle
school late Elementary School where you
start to be like I don't need goggles
I'm not a child anymore I'll just I'll
just jump in like the adults do and just
open my eyes underwater so there was
there was that you know that happened I
was just like yeah yeah I'm I'm also an
adult now I will try it as well so I
jump in I'm just like but instinctively
you're like I don't want to open my eyes
right it's gonna hurt I'm like [ __ ] it
I'm an adult did it once and then my
place you jump with your eyes open no no
no no I jump in with my eyes closed slam
the clothes directly in your eyes
I think that's just gonna hurt anyway no
I didn't even do I I remember I didn't
even jump in the pool I was on the edge
of the pool and I just stuck my face in
the water all right I'm gonna open my
eyes and I did it for like
one second and I was like it feels like
someone's stabbing my eyebrow I think
that's normal though but I pulled my
eyes out and all the whites in my eyes
were just bloodshot red yeah and my
parents were like oh that's that's not
normal that's like that's more red than
usual I think I think that's normal is
it yeah why would
um normally it's like you you're doing
it for like 10 minutes tops like you're
not doing enough 10 minutes I could
barely do it for two seconds I I've done
like whole swimming sessions like an
hour doing it and it [ __ ] hurts
afterwards but it's like I've got to see
where I'm going just buy some goggles
one session
yo Sailors like Sailors in the [ __ ]
heavy or something like yeah oh no I'm
drowning but I can't open I can't see
anything I don't have my gold
[ __ ] that's true that's true I mean I
I'm not I'm not like I mean if I need I
don't like it but if I need to see
underwater
I've never brought goggles to the beach
oh yeah no I'm not in the beach either
but I'm also not opening my eyes on the
water when I'm at the beach no I try not
because most times yeah water in your
eyes yeah no I get like a little you
know Splash so so is so it is blind
you're like my I have chlorine ten
simply in my eyes but I also have I I
but I realize that it's not just the
chlorine for me it's that like now now
like if I stare at a TV for more than
five minutes without my blue eyeglasses
I get a headache this episode is
sponsored by Harry's guys we've been on
the road on tour and if there's one
thing I really miss doing it's having
that nice clean shaved face and with
that incredibly sharp races and refills
that arrive in the nick of time Harry's
is the official sponsor of cutting it
close as I've mentioned a million times
on the show I use Harry's all the time
and religiously it really does the
reason why is because the shave is
better than any other razor I've ever
used the refills are cheap as hell the
blades are sharp and precise and I just
always get the cleanest shade did you
know Connor and audience right now you
can get Harry starter set for just get
this three dollars three dollars
plus you'll get a free travel size body
wash the set includes a 5 blade Razer
weighted hand or foaming shave gel and a
travel cover a 16 value but just three
dollars
and all you have to do is visit
harrys.com trash test it's that simple
so no matter how busy things get stay
fresh with Harry's get your hairy
starter set today and you'll also get a
free travel size body wash just go to
harrys.com trash taste the tariffs.com
trash taste Link in the description down
below back to the episode do you need
yeah do you need to use dark mode for
everything yes are you dark mode because
I'm not an [ __ ] I just think light
mode looks like [ __ ] yeah it's like and
also I don't want to be that guy while
I'm lying in bed and my partner is next
to me
the only way the light mode is good is
like because the windows UI looks like
[ __ ] let me see let me say you dark mode
[ __ ] play [ __ ] up too much okay
hi I'm I'm a light mode user yes I'm I'm
out of myself right now okay that's
probably why your eyes like [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's why because you're blinding
yourself every night I've been blind my
entire life What's it gonna do make me
more you're literally like make me more
blind every time you've opened up
Twitter it's just like a Cod flashbacks
come on it's white so don't let the view
it is it is the people who use light
mode are people Psychopaths can't can't
get over the five second difference of
the changing the dark mode and be like
it's different people like oh I don't
like it it's different take it back no
like the moment you it for one day
you'll be like I'm a [ __ ] idiot yeah
I never went back I I I have used dark
mode on like some apps and I'm like I
like 10 seconds 10 seconds Discord
that's it my discord's still dark mode
and I'm like yeah I don't I don't
Discord in light mode is unforgivable I
don't even know what this is
okay this mod live mode just looks ugly
that just looks like let's see it's
horrific but like everything else I've
switched to dark mode I'm like I kind of
I like the brightness I like the
brightness I do not use Twitter in I
looked up Discord light mode
like white mode mean do you want you
want to check my Twitter
oh my God
who uses Discord like this yeah okay
Discord Twitter I I like it in like mode
okay I can't remember if there was a few
studies or something a while back that
was like I it was measuring the impact
on which ones but a few darker light
mode I couldn't remember if there's a
conclusion I remember that there was
something along the lines of
um what light mode is could be better
because it's more reminiscent of say
books or paper yeah because I was gonna
say like Joey like you you like I'm in
bed okay I want to read manga yeah what
am I gonna do switch the manga to dark
mode manga doesn't have a dark mode you
know I Read Manga in my [ __ ] phone
um oh that's one of them yeah okay okay
one of the big reasons I can't I think
it's too bright and I would I would
argue that a lot of manga is more dark
than light a lot of the drawing is black
it's literally on white paint what are
you talking about yeah
there's more ink on the paper than white
what are you doing
what are you doing it's arguably more
dark than it is like okay maybe it's
something like berserk but like tell me
berserk is like berserk is a dark
fantasy of course he's gonna have so
many [ __ ] like
but if I'm reading like pump team epic
then that's like mostly why I'm just
saying it's a live dog a lot of Doc in
them you know a lot of them have a lot
of words
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure even the
most hardcore light mode person is
watching this bite now being like no
Connor I'm trying my best
I I think there's saying the manga
argument is very negligible in terms of
is that light mode or not because
there's gonna be some we're not saying
dark we're not [ __ ] knocked over yeah
who the [ __ ] it's not all dark
what we're trying to say is that
generally like the background and a lot
of that stuff is dark which is nice and
it's better because the phone is backlit
you know well the thing is because like
it's not traditional the reason I
genuinely like light mode is because
you've never tried dark mode I have
tried dark mode no I I I okay the best
actually the best mode is the one where
it switches for you automatically
depending on the time of day because the
thing is I wake up screen dimmer yeah
the screen no not the screen dimmer
there's a little there's a literal mode
that will switch on on some apps that
will switch from light mode to dark mode
like an in-car GPS yeah yeah yeah kind
of that's like the best mode but like I
like when I wake up and I just have like
the brightness of the screens okay one
thing I genuinely generally welcome to
your future robot slaves look genuinely
because I'm someone who needs a lot of
sunshine you know I I like my sunshine I
like I like my brightness the way my
body are we gonna go do you touch grass
I also enjoy sunlight but you know what
I do when I want to enjoy sunlight I
[ __ ] go outside and look at something
okay open my curtain okay
obviously you guys have obviously you've
never lived in England when sometimes
it's just like a [ __ ] cloudy day and
it's just the most
I would not live in like the northern
hemisphere of like Finland in the middle
[ __ ] nowhere
I will take any brightness Source I can
get the brighter the room is the happier
I am the more awake I am the more that's
probably why you're blind because you
just flash banging your eyes every day
okay phone's lightness is not even
remotely comparable to a light in say
like a room like a ceiling light or
anything it's not even remotely they
also take every selfie
they also take every selfie with the
flash on no no
to just be a bunch of [ __ ] phone
screens just lighting up the room like
what these lights are totally different
type of like I I do not want the
artificial it's like I want white walls
in my room I feel so much nicer
sunlight does feel so much nicer but
sometimes you're in a room where you
can't get enough sunlight sometimes
you're in a place where you know there
isn't enough natural light and there's
just the lighting on the ceiling or the
lamps the last Light I think about
getting to fix that problem is my phone
okay yeah I will say having having like
having a bright mode on your PC is much
better to me like it it feels for the
argument's sake I do use Windows Live
mode yeah because the dark mode I don't
know what they did to it it looks
[ __ ] horrendous really yeah do you
use it and I use I didn't even know
there was a dog it just doesn't look
good I'm not sure why oh like it's all
it's it try it we'll do it later okay I
mean what looks bad about light mode
what what actually I don't get what are
you why everyone and says it looks bad
okay it's just really it's like having
like bread from a store and then you
know and like you don't know a bakery
exists out there fresh bread right right
you're really clutch it does white light
mode does everything it's it's a very
viable option but it's just because you
don't know about the joyous ability you
can't just say it it hurts my eyes no no
it doesn't no because it does it hurts
my eyes I just think dark mode
that's exactly what I'm saying dark mode
it looks better that's what we have
after dark because it's a better version
of trash
just a dark version of trash test this
disgusting this is uh this is light mode
sorry if you a lot of the apps just like
I Twitter to me is is I I can't unsee it
as a dark Mode app it just it when I see
it on light mode I'm like this is
[ __ ] like when you watch those
documentaries and that you know they
play all like the millions of tweets
pop-up and they have the white
background I'm like it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro we sold more after dark merch than
we did Regular trash days motion
coincidence I think not people like dark
mode people like the vibe but there's a
shirt there is people not light I know
it's not reflected well you're wearing
the light mode one man you got white
there Connor what are you doing does
that hurt your eyes
what is is that apps are better in dark
mode
yeah you're on I rest my case
there I think there is a sect of us
light mode users we have been oppressed
by the dark mode
at least tell me okay okay of course
dark Mode's gonna yeah at least how do
you know that how do you know because
we're a [ __ ] weird
no no they first stay in their [ __ ]
man caves right yeah let's listen at
least tell me all right if you're if
you're you know you're in bed right
you're just before you go to bed
you're gonna be you know you're gonna be
uh you know on your phone going through
Twitter and stuff like that before you
go to bed right you do that yes okay how
bright do you have your phone how bright
do I have like when it comes to the
brightness meter on your phone right
right is it all the way to the top or is
it all the way to the bottom or
somewhere in between well I try not to
go on my phone if if the room is dark
yeah if you're in a pitch black room and
you and you want to go on Twitter before
you go to bed how right is your phone
usually don't because okay like to me
like that's that's one way to just not
get asleep right right
I sleep great yeah great sleep yeah look
I'm saying it's it's a good habit just
because like it gets your mind in the
process of getting to sleep healthy
habits healthy habits
from a guy who uses light I am going to
preach this okay I'm preaching this
right now Joey listen if I have any
healthy habits I'd stop drinking God
that's I don't care about that all right
so you'd rather you you'd rather you'd
rather use I think that's [ __ ]
though what you're saying is the
healthiest way is to not look at your
phone what we're arguing is uh well I'm
not really he's arguing around here I'm
I'm you should look at the dark mode if
you're gonna look I'm arguing that the
best mode is the mode that switches
automatically automatically for you but
if I had a choice between dark mode and
light mode I choose light mode because I
don't want to switch manually to light
mode every time when I wake up in the
morning and see all the boys that you
don't like about dark mode what is it
that I don't like about dark mode it's
not that I don't like dark mode is that
I prefer light mode or why do you prefer
light mode I just I literally just said
because I I said because I like the
brightness in my life Joey I like this I
like the light okay I go towards the
light I'm a [ __ ] moth okay
I like the brightness why is that a bad
thing I like the brightness even darker
light mode light mode
everything everything you know
everything I think everything aside from
Discord because I see I think Discord
Discord is actually War crime I think we
can all agree on YouTube light mode uh
everything's so bad in life
there's what is wrong with YouTube live
mode literally do what the [ __ ] logo
has white in it you know what a logo has
white in it it's like three pixels it
doesn't matter okay you know what I hate
about YouTube is that you open it right
so you open YouTube yeah and it does
okay I did win this up sometimes right
it'll just open white and then turn to
dark oh yeah
I want to see a single I think they
fixed that recently though but a lot of
people you know uh it's something going
to consider yourself if you're making
thumbnails yeah I gotta make it for dark
and light mode to make sure let's get on
both I've never thought about it I don't
I don't I don't consider like so do you
so yeah when you make your thumbnails do
you actually consider that no white
background no nothing I try not to make
it yeah I look at both because I had it
in dark mode so I gotta be because
people leave on the default right oh I
just assumed no one watches YouTube in
line mode
no it's default unfortunately yeah it
just means that our calls will never be
the best yeah sad that's just I just
don't I I okay people are lazy and they
just don't change the defaults because
they get used to something and then
they're too scared to change it like
this guy have you changed it I guarantee
he wouldn't turn I have changed it I'm
saying this is not do not love me with
the same people who are still using
Internet Explorer because they don't
have to change
like a little little science experiment
what if you change the dark mode for a
week I'll change the light mode for a
week and then we can decide and see who
has the better eyesight at the end
do you think there is a chance you're
going to convert to light mode
I I started in light mode and then I I
ironically I saw the light and I I
didn't like it so I went to the dark and
that's what I'm in narrative so I I've
had the light mode because where I
started yeah I mean I had the life and
then I learned about dark mode
afterwards and so I was like oh I'll try
this new dark mode thing out and I'll
say oh I much prefer because it doesn't
blind me every morning look I'm just
saying like [ __ ] light mode is the
pizza crust of the app world okay like
it feels exactly the same where you
where if you choose to use [ __ ] light
mode people act like you've just
committed a [ __ ] War crime or
something you know a war crime against
their eyes or something okay that's
that's what it feels like okay
all right what do you think uh is
winning right now in the poll I know
it's dark mode why do you think my stock
mode because because you you dark mode
guides are so [ __ ] vocal about it
you you dark mode users because I'm sick
of being on the [ __ ] train look
across and the person next to me and
they have [ __ ] light mode beaming in
my eyes you uncivilized [ __ ] you stuck
what is look it doesn't matter what the
polls says I want to guess 90 10. what
do you think
probably United yeah do you think it's
that much maybe okay that's what I feel
like I could have gone to my head I'd
have been like that's what I feel like
40. really really what is it now
um well let me um how long has the
Philippines wait wait how how many 3 000
votes yeah 95 Darkness
so so I said okay which one of the boys
uses light mode confess your sin someone
replied it's gone Connor is going to
defend dog mode like his life depends
Joey is gonna say I can see both sides
but prefers documents I feel so cool
down anyone who says light mode is a
sociopath look if there are 500 light
mode users in the world I am one of them
I am one of them if there are 10 live
mode users in the world I am one of them
I will defend light mode until till my
dying breath okay I don't care how many
of you guys are there because there's
one or more of me of you if there's one
more of me I found a brother okay like
an AAA meeting but for light mode
why didn't we convert any time to like
flickers or anything
we're gonna start a movement it's a
revolution okay we're taking back the
rise mode the resistance
it's one of the things when I when I
realized that doctor was a thing I tried
it out I was like oh this is much better
it's like it's like having a wrong
fitting t-shirt for the longest time and
then you realize oh oh it can feel like
this that's what it felt like to change
right right like a pair of boxes that
didn't quite fit as nicely but you
didn't realize that so you're only pay
for everybody was the app that convinced
you was it Discord because I swear for
me it was Twitter Twitter I started off
with Twitter because I think
a lot of apps don't even tell you that
dark mode exists I didn't know it
existed me neither and then I think I
went on Twitter one day and they showed
the dark mode yeah they had dark like
true dark and like the dim darker Navy
dark I use that one love that one looks
amazing and then I thought hi what if
there's dark mode for other apps and one
time I shared my screen on Discord and
it was light mode I didn't even realize
dark mode existed and then all my live
stream people were like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] no okay because like yeah
I was exactly the same so it was like
like I saw it on on Twitter and I was
like oh let me try this out and I was
like see how people screaming it's
amazing
and I was like oh is that like a plug-in
or something what is that have you
realized about most screenshots you see
on Twitter or dark mode yeah with like
tweet memes don't think about it yeah
think about it think about it
it doesn't matter how many it does like
I said if everyone was using dark mode
do you think people what they want that
is that is why take away that is why
this is the most depressed Society we've
had in all of history I guess this is
why this is the depressed generation
okay we haven't had that yet okay this
is why mental health is such a big deal
now it's because too many people are
using dark mode
I go to my Better Health session
after I lost my job and I use my
three-month coupon uh it's remittance no
it's because it's because people are
using light mode to substitute for some
social media that's why you're trying to
grow like a planet
come on bro is that all I can feel the
cells getting energy in my body
photosynthesis please don't be like a
cannabis plant bro trying to grow from
artificial life to this house
oh my god oh how the fun are we going to
stop it I don't know welcome to trash
days I can't remember I don't know
because we're talking about haughtiness
oh yes let's talk about Isis yeah one of
the most interesting videos I've ever
seen actually is your Dogma like artists
um the artists who drew like as the
world would look if you didn't have
glasses yeah yeah right
um I remember seeing a video Once of
like a blind artist and he was born like
without eyes yeah and I was like one of
the most interesting videos I've ever
seen because this guy's an artist but
obviously he's never seen anything in
his life
um and he describes like what colors the
concept of colors of what he thinks
right and he's like oh I think I've seen
this yeah and he's like I don't get it
like people people have tried to
describe colors to me people have tried
to describe colors to me and it's such
an interesting concept of how do you
describe colors to someone who's never
seen colors right now you can describe
Orange
I think the general consensus because
yeah I remember seeing that video a
while back the general consensus is like
when you just uh when you talk about
things like the color red for example
right you think of like hot yeah or like
blue is like a cool color yeah but when
you think about it it's like that
doesn't mean anything yeah he's like so
people describe to describe Reza's hot
it's like what the [ __ ] does that mean
yeah what does that mean why is hot a
color
plus how the [ __ ] does that make sense
because like blue can be hot as well if
you're talking about a blue flame yeah
yeah exactly so it's like it doesn't
when you think about it it's like okay
how do you describe say like this
particular shade of purple to someone
it's trash days just trash dating it
it's like oh of course of course I've
seen trash teeth but wait a minute wait
a minute I've heard trash days before so
is his art good or what huh was it good
yeah yeah it's like it's really well I
think I think it's I don't know how does
he know what he's drawing I I think he's
just I might learn am I ignorant am I I
think I think it comes with that whole
concept of like uh you know if you're
born blind or you're born deaf yeah that
is that is normal to that person as it
is for the rest of everyone else who is
born with sight or born with hearing
right yeah it's only I think I remember
like a comedian talking about this it's
only when normal people make it weird
that it becomes weird for them right
because like if someone is born deaf
then it's like well to them not hearing
anything is normal but it's not until
someone's like oh you're deaf oh you
can't can you can't hear music and it's
like don't make it [ __ ] weird for
them they're living fine I mean it's
like if I didn't know like document
existed it wouldn't bother me I didn't
know it existed right another when
someone points it out music existed I'd
be like whatever dude yeah exactly
[ __ ] music exactly
but yeah like what's what what was what
I found so interesting is he can still
like he still can imagine let's say like
what a landscape looks like you know and
what yeah you have your own
interpretation of what the description
could be or what you think it is yeah
yeah that would visual you could still
visualize that yeah like I think one of
honestly one of the coolest I'm gonna
call it ability even though it's like
kind of a condition because it it sounds
like a [ __ ] ability is I think it's
called like synesthesia or something
where you one sense is tied to another
yes right which is one which is one of
the coolest things I've ever heard like
I think uh we met uh Baron J John who
actually had synesthesia yeah and like
he was telling his story about how you
know you say a word or you hear a sound
and he sees like a certain color with
yourself yes and I'm like this is this
is like this is the closest we've gone
to like X-Men in real life wait wait
wait wait wait wait hold up so like
um
because let's say you said coffee to me
yeah obviously I'm going to picture
Brown
that's because you're associating it
with the object that exists yeah if
you're talking about say like a very
arbitrary concept that doesn't exist in
the Physical Realm and doesn't have a
form for example
God
I have an image like what color do you
imagine that
uh you know white right but that's
because you're probably thinking about
God
when you say God do you think light mode
uh yeah I guess so yeah okay
okay here's another example here's
another example when I say the number
three what color do you think of gray
why gray I don't know just thought of
that color what about number four
probably green why green though I don't
know it's green when you say color and
four I think green
like because of 420.
I don't think here's the thing I imagine
that it's like consistent right if they
if you always ask them for it would
always be the same color right if you
ask me four knit and then a color I I
would probably say a different color
every time right I really seem like a
[ __ ] year okay so so I looked up on
Google for example right uh synesthesia
is when you for example you hear music
but you see shapes yeah uh or you hear a
word or a name and instantly see a color
uh for example you might hear the name
Alex and C green
yeah so do you have that or are you just
like no oh I think what you were doing
was just like hearing a number speaking
random color green yeah I'd say the
music one was a little sounds a little
familiar definitely seeing shape not
like visualizing shapes to music that
sounds familiar but not not the other
ones right right well then maybe you
might I feel that every music has like a
if you imagined do you know like if you
because it's like you know if you said
like rock in your head maybe you could
visualize what it would look like if you
were to
oh like rock music yeah well it depends
for me I think I think like yeah no
definitely like if you hear enough music
and you get into it then yeah you can
definitely start to like Envision like
I've had moments where I've listened to
a new piece of music and I can Envision
what the music video but I don't
actually see it right but I don't
physically see it yeah you physically
see it yeah you physically see it well
it's like that's that's the condition
that's synesthesia that's that's so it's
like so it's like when you hear the word
Alex yeah your vision your vision
because that color and it's not only
tied to Vision as well I've heard of
some people where you it's tied to like
taste or something so why would this be
a superpower it sounds like a detriment
I want [ __ ] shapes in front of my
eyes all the time well the [ __ ] I want
shapes you just [ __ ] with someone yeah
if you just see me like Alex Alex
it is a real Condition it's one of the
strangest conditions I know I think of
yeah it is I think it's like super cool
because it's like it's because you see
like you see it clearly I'm pretty sure
right yeah well obviously I don't have
something well I don't know I don't know
I've only used when you said the music
thing I said I I feel that it's like I I
didn't you imagine that yeah yeah but no
no you physically see it yeah
yeah with like what font what Graphics
like what I don't know I don't know the
condition like like how would this look
this sounds what you should probably ask
someone any any viewers watching with
synesthesia please explain in the
comments feel free to inform us
Enlighten us this is my ignorance of
where I'm like this sounds too fake this
I I think this is cool but like I I know
that's just because I can't because none
of you have it and none of you can sit
here
yeah it looks like you're explaining it
to me and none of you have it so I'm
like this doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
to me oh yeah of course because I'm like
I can only I can only like imagine what
it's like but you know yeah I mean you
know I definitely can imagine things
like my mind can wonder when I listen to
a piece of music for example I think
anyone can do that but like physically
seeing something is very different huh
you got to be on some like
hallucinogenics exactly if you're a
normal person that doesn't have
synesthesia but for someone like this
it's like being on hallucinogenics all
the time okay so here's WebMD only the
best sources of course one of the most
common responses to seeing lessons
numbers and also colors you might also
see or hear a word and taste food see
here so like so like say for example
what but like not not but I don't think
it it's the word that is associated with
the taste so it's not the same as like
hearing the word bacon and then tasting
bacon it's more like a completely
different thing yes
let's say someone said bacon and they
might I would hear like be realistic
like it might not like that yeah maybe
or vice versa if I said free real estate
okay
okay my ignorance on the subject and
might not understanding of it is not one
of like disgust or yeah I just don't get
it and I want to understand because I
think it's different to when for example
like you know if you see a picture of a
lemon then you start salivating I think
it's very different to that because that
is like an association with priests
that's that's an association with
pre-existing knowledge of what that is
but your brain is [ __ ] weird enough
where it could easily make pre-existing
bonds or ties to stuff oh of course I
mean again that explains the whole thing
of like looking at a picture of a lemon
and salad yeah yeah I suppose that's
because I remember they did that when I
went to go get a PCR test in Japan like
at the PCR Center they have pictures of
like sour plums and lemons there to help
you celebrate
it was really funny I saw this
right now the explanation makes it sound
like you like I I could believe it if
you
um you hear something and then it's a
very faint picture but like if it like
was obstructing your view like what like
I don't know I don't know like I want to
know I'm sure there's different levels
of severity to it maybe it's like a
light Hue or maybe it's just like
putting a piece of green paper in front
of your face I don't know honestly
anyone says thank God I'm not a [ __ ]
doctor if someone came with this [ __ ]
I'd be like all right [ __ ] off
he's just like no you know [ __ ]
I shave this what about you see five
[ __ ] off you stupid come on [ __ ]
office again you see colors and stuff
yeah I can see I can see as well I also
have eyesight
shout out to those doctors that just
like believe people
no I I I know I mean to me it's like I I
want to know more about it because I
don't yeah it's is that like it's like
um a lot of the times I think that are
like personally and uh our brains are
very poor at understanding things we
have no concept of being able to like
feel or experience ourselves yeah yeah
so like when I'm asking all these
questions it's not out of like it's not
real it's like it's just like I just I
just want to know exactly how it feels
and what you're experiencing yeah well I
think that's why it's so hard for us to
like say you know whenever you see any
kind of like charity movement or
something like that it's so hard to
convince people with like facts and
numbers but you hear like you hear a
story and you're like oh okay I get it
there is an issue there's a problem yeah
and it's not again I want to preface
this is not from like because I know
that this could be comparable to like
say mental health and it's like oh well
you know how could you say that you
could argue that doesn't exist because
you didn't feel it or you can't
empathize with it that's not what I'm
trying to say it's that I it's not that
I I'm asking questions because I don't
believe or I don't necessarily uh you
know uh think it's real it's just that I
just want to know you want to get
because I want to feel like I can
understand and what exactly what it
feels like to have this thing it's
really fascinating as well because I
just said I'm just reading more of the
synesthesia thing on WebMD yeah only
trusted sources uh the color uh it says
it's internal mostly the colors are just
in your mind only a few since
that uh see colors outside their body
okay see that's that's what I would
argue right because I how do you
determine that though because when I
hear music sometimes I can like assign
and feel and like if I would like I can
imagine like shapes yeah and stuff to
the music yeah yeah um because that's
just I don't know why but like
physically seeing it well outside
basically seeing it that's that's what I
thought you meant yeah apparently there
are some cases if that's super rare I
can understand that yeah
um but like yeah I feel like this is the
artist getting described to what like
what color is you know of course we're
never gonna be able to like visualize
that because we've never experienced
that so we're like yeah I mean I get it
but I don't get it well because if that
artist had that symptom for example then
it'll be a lot easier
what color is red and it would just be
like oh number four and he's like oh I
get it all right but the reason why you
ask like a billion questions when
someone says oh I have this thing is
that you're like well okay well we're
not gonna just we need to make sure sure
that we figure out what it is that you
you have yeah so we're going to be very
thorough and ask every single question
explain it all to me there's something
not adding up there's something
happening and then you go and contradict
it again later by saying this x thing
it's like yeah I just want to know all
this stuff because I'm like I want to
just hear how it works because sometimes
you hear stuff and you're like that
sounds like you made it the [ __ ] yeah
what are your sources on that yeah yeah
well well you like listen iPhone 12.
but also like the older you are the more
you realize man you're it's a brave but
the brain is a brain is just [ __ ]
weird okay that's like the one thing
that I've never been able to like
understand of like how how your brain is
just this powerful it's going into some
shower thoughts we're going to good
Shadow thoughts now okay like split
personalities yeah not like that like
how how does how is your brain [ __ ]
capable of that okay so that is that is
insane to me it's because there's two
brains
well I think a lot of the time stuff
like trauma can cause that right yeah
it's like it's like a defense it's like
an internal defense for some people for
others it's not but like there's a many
reasons why you're you're brain anatomy
or whatever could have the decision that
this is how you're going to deal with it
or this is what's going to happen yeah
right yeah it's like it's a defense
mechanism the way I always try to like
explain to people if this ever
accommodation never comes up which it
really does but like for example
one thing that weep as humans believe
without a doubt is that when I've seen
something I saw it yes like I 100 saw
this you can't change my mind right and
it's like well no because we have we
have many many occasions where like
witness testimony where they swear they
saw it and they swear on their life and
it's been not not maliciously because
they had no reason to lie and it was
just wrong like it just did not happen
it did not align so like
like the brain memories perception it's
all like almost it changes at times I
mean that's like if your memories can't
be trusted as being fact and and what
you saw like who knows what else to [ __ ]
your brain is making out oh yeah and I
mean you know that's like the whole
basis on like sleight of hand magic for
example it's like your brain immediately
thinks oh that card disappeared yeah but
no it's just your brain just can't keep
up with it it's like our brain is like
an algorithm that has chosen the best
way to do things
yeah you know I actually have a theory
okay going on a slight hand I'm not a
scientist with none of us are sorry guys
this is my theory and of understanding
of stuff I've seen yeah okay so I I have
a theory so you you guys have all felt
Deja Vu right yes of course yes you know
everyone everyone's felt deja vu in one
sense or form even if they've never been
to a place or been in this situation
I've been in this place before yeah I
haven't been to this place before
so like I have a theory that Deja Vu
comes from like you experiencing
basically the same thing in your
imagination maybe through dreams or
something like that because like
possible yeah yeah because I when they
say that you remember all of your dreams
I'm like how that's that's [ __ ] I
remember none of my dreams but I I
believe like some people will say that
yeah you remember all of your dreams
even if you can't recall them and I have
a theory that Deja Vu is your
subconscious brain being like I have
seen this before in my memory somewhere
yeah yeah and come back in 300 years to
find out yeah
have you ever felt jamaivu before what
the [ __ ] is that it's the opposite of
deja vu
that sounds like a dance move
what were you experiencing you're like
I've never experienced it I've never
experienced something before and but you
have
that's a real thing what have you had
what happened I I've never experience
we're just asking
because it's a thing I don't know I'm
pretty sure like Alzheimer's right just
describe Alzheimer's
that's just a fancy word for outside
it's like doctor here's jummy food I
have I haven't been to this place before
even though I have
for myself
that's just Memento yeah I think our
brains are computers in a way they're
very good computers and yeah computers
you know what's my favorite Channel
about the brain because the brain named
itself
think about that for a second
think about that for a second
I realized the moment I was going to say
it yeah I knew you're going to say I'm
like [ __ ] this
I love that one
I love Connor just like processed for a
minute and like nope it's not worth it
[Music]
although one of the freakiest videos
I've ever seen which I still [ __ ] if
I want to go to into like an existential
crisis I watch this video it's like a
cpg gray video called like there are two
of you or something like that okay where
he explains that you know there's the
right side of your brain and then
there's the left side of your brain yeah
right
and uh so that's connected Vera nerve
but there have been cases in medical
history where they've had to like
disconnect the nerve connecting the
right and left side of the brain yeah
um and you can still function as a human
being right right but
only I think once one other side of your
brain is like is in charge of speech
right yeah yeah and the other is like
part of like motor skills and stuff like
that right yeah I mean yeah I believe
that one side uh if I remember this
correctly one side of your brain control
was one side of it and the other one
controls the other side of it yeah so
there have been cases where you've had
the split brain
and uh they've given like an apple to
let's say the rights uh they've they've
put like the right
I'm going to take a toilet break and I'm
going to watch the video and then I'm
gonna explain it because that's too easy
and that's too simple guys you know it's
time this episode sponsors my box to our
favorites Japanese snack box boxing
sources rare snacks from all over Japan
and partners with family businesses to
create signature treats you can't find
anywhere else this month is the month of
October but instead of celebrating
Halloween in Japan we are celebrating
the Autumn Courier which is when the
trees turn into that beautiful reddish
yellowish orange you've already just
seen this this is a used UK I am a fiend
for Yuzu so let me just try this out
this is definitely the month for you
here for sure
let me try this I can smell the use it
from here oh so good well if you love
using gone then you can also down it
with a little bit of earl gray horses
shirt as well absolutely beautiful tea
pairing with some music
this is so good I'm probably gonna have
to order another box I'm not gonna lie
we've received these boxes every single
month and Destroy them so if you want to
try some red Japanese snacks and support
does and support Japanese family
businesses and our channels click the
link in the description down below and
use coupon code trash taste to get 15
off your first box you order are you
gonna boxer for the sponsor back to the
episode this is for the brain right so
every explanation you have for it is is
not a who don't even [ __ ] know what's
happening we don't know what's happening
it's way way complicated more than we
could ever imagine yes it's the brain
trying to understand the brain exactly
the brain we don't it's too much we
don't know what the brain is so when
people are like the left side right side
made one personality one good it's like
no that's oh that's it we'll pack it in
there thank you so much thank you so
much for that
oh okay thanks so we know when to stop
the scientists stop wasting all the
money don't research anymore it's the
brain trying to convince itself on how
it works we like easy answers because
we're humans and it doesn't [ __ ] work
like that no of course not and that's
why like study is still being done but
like I think you know with modern
technology we are getting a much better
obviously yeah I mean we're gonna take
educated I reckon one like surface level
at this point in time it's like
understanding how the brain works all
right tell me about the [ __ ] left and
right side and why you're wrong all
right
why I'm wrong okay wrong predisposition
Conor's brain is like I don't believe
any of this this is [ __ ] brain is a
lie he's lying he's lying come on my
brain is like don't trust that brain all
right that brain is full of [ __ ] Connor
all right so
there have been cases where for medical
reasons uh they've split the left and
right side of the brain so they've split
any kind of connection between the left
and right and the right side of the
brain but your left and right side of
the brain is in charge of different
things so there have been cases where it
feels like to a patient of one of these
conditions that the like they would make
her they would try to pick something and
then their other hand would kind of like
disagree with them they they noticed
some disagreement with disagreement with
that right and so they they have done
some tests right where they say they
give a command to let's say the left
side of the brain and it's beloved
division give a command to the left side
of the brain like pick up uh Rubik's
Cube and they show nothing to the right
side of the brain right and they ask
them okay did you pick up an object and
the the guy answers because only one
side of it is in charge of speech no
didn't pick up anything and then so they
give the instruction for like the left
side to put the Rubik's Cube on the
right side and the scary thing is that
because one side is in charge of
reasoning they'll just like make up a
reason that that a cube has just
suddenly appeared in their hand they'll
let they'll they'll reason that
something like oh I've just always
wanted to solve a Rubik's Cube or
something like that and that is like
terrifying yeah I believe that this
experiment could have taken place and
could have happened yeah I just don't
buy into the whole the right and left
side thing and I mean it seems to me I
mean that's your right side of your
brain that's your reasoning logic side
operation when we took many people
so I also Google dicks I'm pretty sure I
heard this was a myth one time yeah I
Googled it and apparently this is also
there is some very very very very slight
truths to have different areas of the
brain work but it's not that easy where
it's just left and right obviously if
you start cutting the brain up weird
shit's gonna happen yeah like the dude
who had a whole [ __ ] pipe rammed
through his brain and survived yeah who
started being way more Angry like when
you take out uh the is it the frontal or
frontal cortex for the cortex yeah I
think you people start acting way more
Angry yeah get way more
uh I guess what's the word like isn't
that like your reason and logic side of
your mind yeah I mean you do okay from
what I understand you can't just like
cut the same thing out of every single
brain and the same results are going to
happen like it's like if you see there
are some parts though like the amygdala
for example which is like the part of
your brain that operates emotions right
if you cut that out of any person then
maybe not all of your emotions are going
to disappear you're not going to turn
into like a [ __ ] it's whatever but
like a lot of emotions is controlled by
that part of your brain so if you cut it
out then you'll definitely be less
emotive oh I just thought they were
called kudaris yeah kudres are just
people
I don't know I think even remotely
pretending like we understand one tenth
of brain science
I took psychology one in college
tries to attempt to be to be brain
Science
question of like what are you you know
can you bring this topic up if none of
us know [ __ ] anything about it are we
allowed to talk well we can yeah we can
make speculations I'm betting the
brain's gonna [ __ ] end tomorrow
speculating well it's like not if if not
even [ __ ] you know professional
scientists who work on this kind of [ __ ]
day in and day out fully understand
what's going on then I think that leaves
enough Liberty for people have no idea
to talk about it as well also like
because it's like talking about this
season oh is that like a bad I don't
know well I don't know like I feel like
that argument is used to discredit
scientists I hate that argument no but
of course but like what we are talking
about in this episode isn't going to
hurt someone no no like someone's not
you know no one watching this is going
to be like oh [ __ ] I already got my
frontal low back feelings I'm feeling
too many things told me to cut my
amygdala out you know no one's gonna
[ __ ] No One's Gonna Do That
I mean it's [ __ ] insane that at one
point you know a lobotomies existed I
just I just find that insane you know
how that was just like a tree is there
any times where it's I still used not no
no
no
I hope I really hope not I think they
very quickly realized that you are just
basically killing someone inadvertently
but like I I mean I mean it's just the
equivalent of when you have an old CRT
and you just start hitting it on the
side to make it operating in take out
your brain yeah have a brain transplant
yeah yeah yeah you know your brain is
[ __ ] for some reason yeah
keep you alive you know whatever and
they put a new brain in it I don't know
they can't do that I'm pretty sure but
um
brain transplant it's possible for some
reason we can keep you alive we can give
you a new brain yeah yeah are you still
you no
no no he just you just described the
[ __ ] plot of ghost in the show
literally yeah it's like if you if your
soul is inside of an Android is that
Android really is your soul in your
brain
women
now we're getting into like the
religious terrorists [ __ ] what's the I
love that [ __ ] what's the name of
that thing go on go on say a thing about
the new one he's gonna bring up a meme
they're really deep thing so like Uganda
Knuckles
[Laughter]
uh uh thesis oh yeah where you replace
everything right right right yeah do you
want to explain what the ship of thesis
is for people yes so obviously there's
this this question that is arised where
if you start with a ship let's say
you're getting a long Voyage from the UK
to America [ __ ] knows how long back then
yeah and every now and then while your
ship is going along this route you know
a plank of wood snaps off here maybe you
change some wood here you found after
doing this whole journey that your
entire ship has sort of changed nearly
all of its parts and the ship is kind of
a little bit different and it's not the
same ship but it's still called the ship
of thesis yeah is it is it still the
same ship even if you change every part
over time well technically speaking if
we're getting into shower thoughts
territory humans are also that way
because it's like we're constantly
reproducing cells in our body cells die
and then we make new cells to replace
those older you know you replace your
skeleton as well right yeah yeah so
here's the question do you knew that I
didn't yeah yeah yeah so you you there
is a point where you literally replace
every cell in your body yeah you replace
every cell in your body right so
basically us now there is not a single
cell in our body right now that is the
same cells that we had when we were why
am I getting [ __ ] thank God beta cells
right now they're replacing my good
shells with shittier old cells stop stop
making me old no but here's the thing
right here's another shower thought
newer cells are still making you older
how does that work because they're
copying it themselves Joey they're just
copying over and over again okay but are
you the same person that you are as a
baby if all of the cells that you had as
a baby are now non-existent in your body
because they've been replaced with newer
cells you're not the same person as
Hostess right huh it's all mitosis what
what's mitosis cells duplicate okay oh
okay yeah but they're duplicating
okay but it's my [ __ ] fault but I'm
introducing McDonald's to the mix that
would have been fine if I gave them what
they wanted but no I had to bring a Big
Mac and many milk shakes and then the
cells started [ __ ] duplicating like
crazy so [ __ ] dying
do you know I'll find [ __ ] shitty and
dumb what like you know this argument if
you tell me something dumb I'm gonna
kill you no it's just like it's just
like cool like McDonald's all this fast
food [ __ ] pizza bad for you why is your
body making them taste good why no no I
think that's how it is
the argument of all the healthy [ __ ]
tastes gross and all the bad [ __ ] for
you tastes good yes that's that is if
that isn't the biggest troll your brain
has played on you bro like I don't know
what it is I thought Evolution was meant
to like help you you know why why have
we not evolved to a point where at least
healthy foods had like tasted a bit
better because humans are privilege this
isn't even be a question right yeah if
we were to evolve as say a species and
you know how we're like oh yeah [ __ ]
rats they love [ __ ] peanut butter
they love it they love it right why do
we not all like the same things
what do you mean why do we not all enjoy
the same Foods
it's blunt
I'm just saying I'm just I'm just saying
what you're asking is for us to be
programmed the same where we just think
that every like oh carrots are top 10
delicious uh food everyone on Earth
agrees okay but here's the question
right why is it that humans turned out
that way but animals you know you know
God didn't like this whatever mystical
[ __ ] made the Earth didn't make pizza we
did that yeah we came up with that [ __ ]
right if you were like uh this weed [ __ ]
this uh cheese stuff that we figured out
how to make we should start combining
[ __ ] we did that that's not that they
didn't well I think when Evolution
happened they didn't know that the Big
Mac super Royale was gonna exist
they weren't prepared that's on us the
one we threw that into them one thing
that can be Darwin a [ __ ] big mac oh
my God
also another question another [ __ ] up
Evolution has led us to the Big Mac
sauce we you we keep saying this
Evolution thing like every evolution is
good not every evolution is good what's
a bad Evolution trait that we got think
of like half the [ __ ] birds that died
how do you die out as a bird you gotta
be really [ __ ] trolling to die out as
a bird that's the whole point of
evolution Connor so it's a vital of the
finish what are you talking about so the
point is you're implying that every
single evolution is a good Evolution not
true not every evolution it turns out to
be as beneficial as others that's why
only the best one keeps going right
maybe we are the humans that are not
doing good but we just feel how to
survive anyway but we're evolving into
shitty traits but we're just really good
at [ __ ] slapping a massive Band-Aid
on it think about it right yeah I mean
that's that's a genuine argument yeah
implying that every evolution is good
not every single level
the way you're using the word no no no
evolution is the whole point of
evolution is survival of the fittest if
if we we broke the game if we evolved
we [ __ ] it up what I'm trying to say
is every evolution should be a good
Evolution because if it isn't then we
would die off but yes I believe we have
gotten too smart and we have broken the
Evolution game okay what if for example
what if we are just we're probably just
another like Pawn in this game right
like the next evolution of humanity is
might be the newer version and this
version of us might be the ones that die
out in a couple thousand years who the
[ __ ] no here's the thing right yeah if
we truly lived in a [ __ ] Evolution
let's do it right yeah people who had
like incurable diseases would would die
out yes right but we don't let that
happen because we're not [ __ ]
monsters we're trying to help people
exactly we have evolved I guess empathy
what's the most powerful trait a heart
a soul Evolution doesn't care about
about your feelings well then we we
evolved evolution is just the epitome of
get good so [ __ ] your feelings the first
humans yeah yeah whatever the [ __ ] they
were yeah false yeah we even cared about
other weaker members of the the group in
evolution we don't know why why did we
evolve to be like this I don't [ __ ]
know it's not like and realistically
it's not a a trait that helps us to
survive in any way but but
imagine that humans don't you're
suggesting then that only humans are
creatures that are able to feel empathy
no that's not true why do any creatures
develop it I mean it could be beneficial
I mean because it's beneficial to the
past if you have like a herd kind of
like culture then if they didn't exist
in animals packs wouldn't exist but we
like we've gotten to the point where
we're like we're not concerned about the
next evolution of human beings we're
just trying to [ __ ] get everyone to
get alive well the thing is we don't
we're not concerned about it because we
haven't been around long enough to feel
that change yeah right like like birds
for example have been around for
literally millions of years so obviously
they felt that change humans have only
been around for like what a couple
thousands but we see we see uh changes
in every like generation of people you
know like of course like you know today
[ __ ] that we did yeah us today are
nothing like humans a thousand years ago
yeah no I I I I I that's Evolution
already and that there are some right
taller yeah we're taller yes we're more
Alpha yeah
John Wick to get our [ __ ] juice you
know what I mean like we had to make
that [ __ ] up
yeah I mean there are like there were
like habits within us that you know that
we don't understand yeah and we still
have and I've you know people think it's
due to Evolution like I don't know why
people like you see someone yawning and
you feel like the need to yawn
you're like talking Evolution like
ayon you yawn no that's true
tell me tell me why that happens can we
see someone yawns it sends from your
eyes it sends a signal to your brain
where your brain says you're next okay
oh this might be the most scientifically
inaccurate traffic of all time but [ __ ]
it let's roll
this isn't science this is shower
thoughts yeah right so humans right
great great awesome so I like them our
priority is to make as many of us as
possible yeah if you think about the
yeah the survival Instinct of us right
Japan's sweating right now yeah but why
why why do like none of us give a [ __ ]
about doing it what you
that doesn't even have to do with the
fact
it's not even about that it's like every
human I think most humans on planet
Earth can agree that I think
subconsciously we're all thinking right
now [ __ ] planet's dying we have to save
the planet you ask someone how do we do
it everyone's like
I'm [ __ ] know we know how to do it
but the people in charge on [ __ ]
doing it yeah exactly see lack of
empathy
I mean it's it's lack of like it's it's
a bad trait of the human mind I guess if
we're going into this place where we
can't really conceptualize a problem
this vast right we're only able to
conceptualize literally either stories
we hear about or most of us our
immediate problems and the immediate
issues that's the real shower thought
did we evolve to develop empathy or did
we evolve further where we think we have
empathy
no no that's [ __ ]
do we actually have empathy did we just
build the knowledge where we think that
empathy is a healthy social construct do
you think because let's be real if like
why do you think for example every
zombie apocalypse film that happens
right immediately it's like oh the the
monsters want the zombies the monsters
were within we're the real monsters all
right
because at the end of the day when it
comes to actual survival right like
think of every apocalyptic movie you
don't see people being [ __ ]
empathetic they're the ones that die
first yeah that's a zombie movie though
okay yeah but say for example okay if
it's like okay here's where it's all
came from right yeah right is it you
know human beings have have the natural
um want to be accepted in their like
group yeah that's what we've just
evolved to do yes empathy is just a
branch of that it just came from that
yeah because it's just a social
construct yeah but and it just boils
down to the need that we want for the
government we just want to fit in
do you think we've gone too smart maybe
because here's the thing you know we're
done look at what we're [ __ ] doing to
the planet we're clearly dumb as [ __ ]
but the thing is the thing is we got
smart enough to [ __ ] it up but not smart
enough to figure out how to fix it yeah
as a group right I think any creature
that develops the science of thinking
about science we haven't gone too far of
making stuff yeah and they're not
thinking about how it's going to work
but also and then just implementing it
yeah but also like for example you you
talked about you know the you know it
should be
um human nature to self-preserve you
know to make more of us to preserve the
human race but we've gotten so smart
that in some places of the human race
we've gone smart enough to just not make
that decision yeah you know which which
completely we've gone to the idea now
that it's not a natural instinct Joe
Rogan conversation
I haven't even had any DMT I I wanna I
wanna shoot some [ __ ] horse
tranquilizer or something is that what
you do is that what you're doing you're
all holding imaginary blocks right now
everyone will all be holding up everyone
must think we'd be like high as [ __ ] man
if I was like 90 years old and had
classes you guys would just think I'm
the expert like I'd be honest so you
gotta talk well that's why he's got the
glass I wouldn't even plan for this [ __ ]
I just happened to bring glasses yeah
yeah [ __ ] it's I don't I don't know I
feel like these are damaged [ __ ] we are
we are dumb no we are soda we've
developed really specific parts of our
brain to think that we're smarter but in
reality we're still [ __ ] dumb in a
lot of that actual like apes we're still
Apes we're just monkeys in shoes yeah we
we're Apes floating on a rock like
flying through space but we've been
we've but we're smart enough to know
that we're smart we're smart enough to
develop things that I could exactly like
[ __ ] wipe us off the face of the
Earth We're smart enough we're not only
smart enough to know that but we're also
smart enough to not give a [ __ ] isn't
that [ __ ] up isn't that [ __ ] up
we're fully aware that we are just a
tiny think of dust in space and with but
and yet we are still smart enough to be
like yeah yeah but [ __ ] whatever you
know I I I'm I want to go to work this
is one of the weirdest [ __ ] episodes
of trash days I think we've ever [ __ ]
filmed yo trash taste philosophists
Where You Are
isn't but that's another thing right
it's like I think the the first time
that we saw like actual human evolution
was when Aristotle was just like
philosophy is a thing now yeah right
yeah because it's before because I wanna
because I always found that weird
that like I can't like has it did it
really take that long for Humanity for
someone to be like
I'm thinking about it okay so so why
okay okay okay okay
it's like one day someone was like I'm
thinking about something
no why no this is so short-sighted to
think that there's there's always been
people who have thought about [ __ ]
before that yeah we were really [ __ ]
bad we were like should we keep a record
of stuff no and then Who's Gonna Keep
the records
we were having too many wars we were
killing each other all the time and
Woody when you take over a place are you
gonna keep their [ __ ] thoughts on a
piece of paper [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
burning that [ __ ] [ __ ] down he
was dumb as [ __ ] I killed him right I
don't want to know what he thought I
wanted these people thought so we were
just too busy trying to get by no and
this is not what we're doing today
Aristotle we're just doing that's why no
one cares about climate chains because
we're like they're damn gas prices are
making my survival harder it's all a
full circle
we all keep [ __ ] ourselves and the
people in charge keep [ __ ] us that's
what I'm saying I just love how you make
it sound like Aristotle invented
thinking
I did not he invented the he invented
the science of culture no he's the only
one that we remember and that we
bothered to keep his [ __ ] books
around everyone else we wiped from do
you know how many like civilizations
that Britain probably [ __ ] raided and
just destroyed all their records well
then you're suggesting that before
Aristotle there was no writing no there
was but we just didn't keep it right we
burned it or got rid of it or let it go
to waste but then wouldn't you think
that if someone before Aristotle had
come up with the idea of things
okay okay so make um let's make
something up I'm not sure let's do it
let's do a little let's do a little
thing uh let's say you're the kingdom of
uh what's your kingdom called uh Deez
Nuts the kingdom of Deez Nuts right you
have uh what's your philosopher called
uh [ __ ] Tits McGee so Tits McGee is
made basically like these amazing books
books that the Deez Nuts Empire just
reveres yes well turns out they spent a
little too much time thinking and not
raising their army and Chad gone over
here comes and destroys the kingdom of
these nuts right and he thinks that your
race is just inferior because you
couldn't beat him in battle so let's
destroy all your word stuff because we
don't care about what you say and we'll
take the fun little Bridges you built
and the little toys you built okay then
here's the thinking we don't want that
so we destroyed that because we're gonna
our own guys are smarter because we won
if you guys were smart they would have
thought about it okay then if that's the
case then why did we keep the books from
the Greeks
well I mean it was it was closer to our
time period where preservation of
information mattered more right and
culture started mattering more right
stuff like that started to become more
yeah but it's not like it's not like
when the Greece popped off suddenly
we're all like don't burn the books
everyone no no no no but it's like it's
like it was a gradual thing I mean
there's a number of factors to why that
period and other periods like the Roman
stuff is so well documented right and
it's because a lot of the times as well
when and when these places would get
taken over other the other places taking
them over or whenever the empire fell or
whatever they might also have a respect
for what they've the stuff that they've
also shared or come up with right no I
get that but like if I wasn't specific
people I feel like this is wrong oh no
it's absolutely wrong I have no
information on this this is just like
this is what I'm imagining for like a
thousand of years we were terrible at
keeping any documents about anything
right no but I believe like
I don't believe Aristotle I don't even
know if he was technically there's no
idea he was the first I don't believe he
was the first one I believe he might
have been the first one to actually put
a name to it he was the only one smart
enough to be like I'm thinking really
hard I should probably make I should
probably put this under a word so
everyone can know what I'm doing right
now well they're just thinking yeah
there's other you know other sects of
life that are very closely tied he's
just those he's the world's first five
what religion is just philosophy just in
a nice package in like a DLC like think
about it like the philosophy of like
it's like a religion and that whole
thing is it's like a it's like a whole
package I mean that's a whole lot okay
you know what I mean yeah
it's just a way of life in a way of
agreeing to how you think it is like so
saying that he's the first one is just
completely wrong but but
then right taking that taking that logic
of like you know uh say for example when
The Barbarians took over the Romans
right why was it then that the all the
Roman stuff is so much more well
preserved than say all the stuff before
it even though the barbarians probably
didn't give a [ __ ] about the one I'm not
a historian so I can't tell you that
yeah historians please let us know
because I always wondered that I'm sure
there's because you know what was the
turning point where people were like
maybe we should start respecting other
cultures to the point where we preserve
their stuff I think I think it goes
beyond that it's like you you get to a
point in society where you realize oh
being smart about sorry being powerful
having a powerful Army that maybe there
may be more to life than just taking
over people you know maybe there may be
more to life otherwise half the things
in society wouldn't matter right exactly
but what was the Turning Point that's
what I want to know what was the Turning
Point yeah what was the turning point
between let's burn everything and
everyone that they've ever loved so that
we can pretend it never existed no no no
there's always been empathy right it
just you know at different times in the
Life in history people value different
things right at one point they valued
you know they maybe they realized oh we
could also sell this stuff oh we could
do stuff with this instead of just
destroying it all and pillaging and all
that stuff yes yes yes of course of
course
yes it's just yeah sure I mean like if
like I don't think we should
discredit not even discredit but play
Down how important philosophy very much
philosophy has come to like shape just
how we how we live and everything like
that because you're looking like you
look at like the such different
mentalities and way of thinking between
let's say like the west and like the
East you know and you see a lot of a lot
of people who are in Asia was very much
um their mentality is very much based
from that Chinese philosopher who I
forget the name of now each one
Confucius Confucius Confucius right that
is it's just like it's gone so far back
that it's literally steeped in society
and like yeah the the mentality
that's also another problem is that yeah
Socrates yeah sorry I got that
completely wrong place or every
Aristotle
yeah sorry I'm not educated enough to
know who yes
none of us are educated by the way sorry
it's Socrates so also as well another
thing has to be taking into account is
that our history and our understanding
of it is very English Central
centralized yes we don't know
um we're not we don't educate about like
Asian history or African history as much
as we should so our view of the world
inherently as well already is already
biased as [ __ ] well we're like yeah the
Greeks man there's [ __ ] guys it's
another the dudes who they know what
they're talking that [ __ ] out oh there's
other people uh trying to [ __ ] them I
don't know what's going on you know what
I
mean
yeah
but you know it's like a it's a very
close proximity and it's a history that
a lot of people have subscribed to for a
lot of time so we're biased as [ __ ] yes
course this is hard as [ __ ] because just
this is like too much stuff it's just
too much for any one person to keep
track of everything and have a good
globally minded view on everything so
yeah that's why we haven't evolved far
enough for that yes no we're never going
to we're not brain is already running in
like 110 we might you never know what do
you mean again we might just be the
Neanderthal in the chain of humans we
don't know that Japan has barely figured
out web design I'm not getting I am not
holding up any hopes for our [ __ ]
brain capacity to evolve I mean yeah
yeah it's gonna take millions of years
and I think we'll we're going to invent
something that I can think better than
nothing I mean that's computers we've
already invented something that can
think better than that that's all right
we're gonna be owned by Jeff Bezos uh
that's the point of this
Jeff Bezos is going to be like Angeles
in the sky it's like a big face that
just overlooks the Earth yeah exactly
yeah I mean it's complicated yeah yeah
of course that's the episode it's
complicated but that's why I like these
kinds of discussions because it's just
like a never-ending like list of what
ifs that let's be real it's like no
one's ever gonna [ __ ] know the answer
it's like it's like it's like three guys
in an old person home trying to remember
what they all had for breakfast and none
of them actually no we're just
theorizing
four days ago so [ __ ] you it don't you
know like I feel like uh you didn't even
come into this all her focus on four
days ago what do you mean you missed out
you weren't even here four days ago
holy [ __ ] I have a lot of strong
opinions for being wrong
what do you mean
this many episodes to figure that out
I'm just saying I'm fully aware of that
I I know his brain's developed enough to
tell us at least at least you
acknowledge that at least if you tell me
some facts I'll believe you yeah
if you give me some information you're
like this is what some dude said online
who's very knowledgeable I'm like all
right right I'll just trust the sauce
sometimes sometimes you just like this
is the problem though is that when when
you're like do you believe Socrates
invented velocity or no he didn't invent
philosophy it literally says he invented
philosophy before Socrates there was no
concept of philosophy that we believe
that we know of but like but like I
don't I don't think that he invented
like documented and organized it made it
appealing yes yes I agree I don't think
Socrates was the first person to let's
say think really hard he had tried a
shape don't [ __ ] come at me and tell
me that no nobody else thought about
some of the stuff was he like was he the
first person to let's say make it
marketable
yes make it fashionable
it did he kind of did well people people
would come what a simple trick people
would come to listen to Socrates talk
yes right this is this is no different
than [ __ ] fortune tellers back in the
day this is like another branch of just
talking talking [ __ ] and trying to make
people believe it but this one just
happened to be actually saying
no no but like it's in my mind it's like
the same realm of stuff of where it
began from right it's like the business
of trying to to talk to people and
preach stuff for money and and trying to
do that yes yes well like it's like I
guess what we do I guess we're getting
into it really philosophical discussion
of how do you even Define philosophy oh
God we're doing it again
right now we have things how do you
define we are thinking about this is
like what we have we support so we talk
about sports this time we said that you
know who invented uh no you didn't
invent football you maybe made it like
after like an official sport with rules
and and a league and stuff like yeah you
may be that country did that but like if
you've been [ __ ] kicking a ball
around you know what I mean you're the
first person to kick something around
yeah and play a game with it no but
that's a little bit different because
that's more like instinctual right like
philosophy is inherently we are
instinctively thinking like no yes
humans are but what I'm saying is
animals aren't like a fish isn't saying
that well no but that's what I'm saying
it's like there has to be like a
beginning right wait so you're okay
hello I think this is a giantly I'm
trying to make an account and I think
he's saying this as well other people
before him probably thought about things
I'm not I'm not arguing about lizards
thought about it dude
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
I'm saying like it's interesting how
like inherently philosophy is a human
construct because we have free time yeah
right if lizards have no we're three
times
we're just two no we are we are I mean
you look at dolphins not all of us not
all of you I've seen some of the
comments
what I'm saying is that like you know a
shark isn't swimming around in the ocean
being like oh man that fish look
delicious but why but what about
dolphins though what about dolphins
because dolphins are [ __ ] obsession
with dolphins why why because they're
smart as [ __ ] they're smart as [ __ ] that
they do things on that aren't
unnecessary because they are [ __ ]
awful creatures no no like I believe
that please fact check this but I
believe like dolphins are like one of
the only other creatures that kill
purely for pleasure no I know I know for
a fact
oons are the only creatures on the
planet who have sex purely for pleasure
and why wouldn't they honestly right
[ __ ] evolve man that was some good
Evolution hell yeah man
I wanna I wanna imagine the first
dolphin that was just like I Wanna [ __ ]
so not for babies though I I wanted to
see if because I'm reading about one
time the Apparently like dolphins are
like very aggressive sexually gangs of
two or three male bottlenose dolphins
isolate a single female from the Pod and
forcibly mate with her sometimes for
weeks at a time
nice
to keep her in line they make aggressive
noises threatening movements and even
smack her around with their tails wow
that sounds awful and if she tries to
swim away they chase her down
maybe evolution is not a good thing it's
my favorite shindoell dojo man
like you know dolphins not every
evolution kill Harbor's babies in
Scotland yeah Jesus Christ yeah dolphins
need to chill yeah
obsession with dolphins that's that's
how you know things have gotten too
smart but monkeys do that too right like
yeah but you know come on yo [ __ ]
Dolphins but don't don't let's not
slander monkey here that's right monkey
come on they're just they are without
rules come on at least dolphins have the
decency to not throw [ __ ] at each other
uh bro I would rather you throw [ __ ] at
me than beat up my childhood death but
monkeys do that anymore they don't yes
they don't no my monkey should never do
that I guarantee there's been instances
where a monkey has just gotten fed up
with another one's child and was just
like imma kill that thing
guarantees is it true Connor is it
guaranteed show okay hold up guarantee I
want to say this is I want to preface
this is no different no different to us
they only kill other like maybe the same
species but like they kill another
family's kids to stop them from [ __ ]
breeding we did that yeah but the other
way Connor go get your man
okay
monkeys are engaged in warfare that's no
different from what we do they're just
these dolphins are just killing babies
for fun no reason
well I mean they're both [ __ ]
on the record you'll see you're saying
oh yeah because it's for Warfare they're
doing a service
[Music]
but we don't we don't like yeah we don't
have a kill babies for fun event
well no because we have a thing called a
legal system one of his dolphins are
[ __ ] yeah I agree why do we go
dolphin watching uh because
again it's what we came back to with the
animal survival thing it's all branding
yeah dolphins are branded himself as
cute and they're [ __ ] monsters
but like how come no one goes like
monkey watching because monkeys fight
back
the Dolphins too
also no infectious monkeys because we
know they're one step away from us
they're gonna [ __ ] us out because like
with with an eight you can see how
[ __ ] built they are bro like you know
that thinking [ __ ] have you been close
to a dolphin before I know they can swim
with dogs I know it can [ __ ] you up
right they can [ __ ] you up yeah oh
they're terrifying not as consistently
as monkeys
but also you'd have to like like apes
are like land mammals you know we have
to like go in their Turf together
we should give them the pool yeah what
are they gonna do I'm gonna pull the
plug out yeah well they're gonna do like
come up here and like
yeah
the moment Dolphins evolve where they
can just come up on land and start
smoking the [ __ ] out of you is when we
stop [ __ ] with dolphins when when's
the dolphin boxing event when's that
gonna be when we're gonna put dolphins
in the ring right we could do that with
other animals do that with other animals
oh we're [ __ ] up this episode is
sponsored by zenmarket guys have you
ever seen some of the stuff we bought
that are only available in Japan and
thoughts I want some of that stuff but
you don't know how to order it well
thanks to zenmarket they can do that for
you did you know that Zen Market only
has a 300 Yen service fee that is barely
two USD 300 Yen which is nothing and
because of the Yen's drop in value it is
the perfect time to shop for expensive
items figures bulk purchases no gym
shoes and also you get free parcel
consolidation you can combine multiple
stores into just one parcel guys oh my
God it's that easy and with multiple
payment and shipping methods zenmarket
has 1.5 million customers worldwide so
you know you can trust that's a lot of
weebs so sign up right now and get your
first item with no service fee Link in
description down below back to the
episode get yourself a JoJo SI right let
me let me tell you how much humans have
broken the Evolution game right because
animals now they're that's a legit
survival tactic is putting all of your
points into cuteness right that's like a
legit survival tactic now we're forcing
them to put their points in cute yeah
[ __ ] your son's dead yeah I can make
a cute version of you or you're not
breathing everything why are toy poodle
exists yeah could you imagine that thing
in the heart between the Wilderness
we're terrible but yeah because they
have to like they've got uh you know
Socrates came along and told us how to
think sovereign
yeah it's just like you know we talked
about how [ __ ] dumbass [ __ ] koalas
are yeah you know [ __ ] pandas will do
everything they can to not [ __ ] make
babies they want to be extinct they
literally want to be extinct and humans
are like no you're not allowed to become
extinct we were too cute you know it's
like the Emos of the [ __ ] Animal
Kingdom I I think it's like I don't want
to be here I think there's a lot of it
does it's like our fault but they're
they're going extinct right oh yeah it's
because we just down all their [ __ ]
homes I think so I think if pandas tore
our homes down yeah I wanted to die I
think I think I'd I'd be I wouldn't want
to breed either they just they destroyed
it I think a panda's gonna come with me
like no it's okay don't worry about it
we'll take care of you
and then we have the audacity to show
them Panda porn yeah what is this some
Black Mirror [ __ ] what we shout like
we are Overlord and they started showing
us porn and it's kind of [ __ ] up if
you think about it that's like if
someone like broke into your home and
like ransacked your [ __ ] and then you
lost everything and you're like well I
guess I I don't want to be here anymore
and that same robber came back and was
just like oh don't no it's fine
yeah we'll buy some new furniture don't
worry
I thought that's basically what we're
doing I guess the argument would be that
you know uh the Panda's capacity to
think isn't as good as ourselves
they haven't they haven't discovered
philosophy yeah yeah they don't have
there's no Panda Socrates yet so there's
no really like you know yeah bro this is
why we should never ever like run into
aliens like Humanity
oh yes [ __ ] you know and then we're
thinking the aliens are any better than
us maybe they're just as bad what do you
mean with like you know thinking and
everyone disagreeing to be honest I
don't think it matters I don't think I
think I don't think it matters what we
think yeah because like uh I think what
was it it was it was I think it was
called the 99 problem that was like
posed by some [ __ ] force or something
but it was this like yeah Socrates
he's the only ever person
well like I think it was something along
the lines of like
um and please fact check me on this okay
um but like I think it's something along
the lines of like the the DNA like
genetic difference between uh or
disposition between in like apes like
monkeys and chimpanzees and us is that
uh I think there is like a 99 match when
it comes to like DNA like basic
structural DNA and that one percent that
chimps don't have is what makes us that
that much smarter right ships I saw a I
saw her a [ __ ] thing uh someone
tweeted it was really dumb as [ __ ] they
were like oh well yeah we just have more
DNA so like
and then and then someone applied being
like you know there's more DNA in an
onion than a human yeah yeah it's got
nothing to do with it
it's like I'm smarter than you I have
more DNA well you know you we still have
like lizard dna in us like when when why
do you think Lizardman exists
aside from [ __ ] Mark Zuckerberg you
know the biggest proof that there is
yeah like I believe like when we're
embryos we still like form a lizard tail
that right
no we gotta fact check this now please
fact check that but like
if you're right I I'll I'll give I'll
give you a crisp handshake if you're
right do we evolve with lizard Tails
when when we're babies have we grow I
believe we grow a slight tailbone and
then it disappears but going back to uh
yeah um maybe that's [ __ ] weird if
that is swear to God's favorite toxics
yeah oh I'm sure well isn't the Cox it's
just an after uh oh like you know it's
just the leftovers of the tales that we
used to have as you know when we're
rapes right isn't that what that is
it well isn't that why like the appendix
as well is like just the uh The
Leftovers of the like the second stomach
that supposedly like we used to have bro
the appendix man well don't get me
started on the [ __ ] appendix why do
we have two lungs why not just one just
one big one just one big one why do we
not only have one nostril why do we have
two hearts yes
[Music]
correct yeah yeah I believe that I mean
yeah the human tails think it says that
a half a billion years is
apparently sprouted Tails almost dead
balance yeah yeah so it's just like an
after like do we still evolved but what
I think God is saying is that when we
reproduce now
okay okay
going back to the 99 problem right it's
called the 99 problem because
hypothetically right if an alien species
came to Earth yeah right and they looked
exactly like us right or maybe not even
exactly like this but genetically they
were exactly like us but now it's the
opposite of what we had with the Apes
now we have a 99 disposition between us
the human race and these aliens but the
extra one percent we don't have is what
makes the aliens that much smarter so
much of a difference that is that it's
the equivalent to US between chimps
right so it's like you know we look at a
chimp like playing around with some
blocks and you know the chimp puts the
square block into the square hole and
we're like
very good you know my my son just
learned algebra two weeks ago right that
could be the same thing for the aliens
yeah the aliens would be like oh you're
learning quantum physics or my
five-year-old just learned that the
other day yeah exactly like that's
terrible so like so the real question is
why would aliens right
give a [ __ ] about what we think okay but
like here's his one thing to them we're
probably just like The Chimps yeah
that's that's that's an argument and
that's why it's scary yeah that's why
it's [ __ ] terrified that's why I
don't think we should ever like
encounter aliens at all but like one
thing I've kind of just realized during
this one conversation is that we've
we've had we've had one like example of
evolution yeah the example that's
happened on earth right yeah and uh
We've evolved you know intellect
smartness and we've seen that in animals
one thing I'm kind of noticing now is
that
um the smaller you are the more likely
you are to just be an [ __ ] what if
that's just like what if that's what if
you know you know what I mean well
because you realize that you can [ __ ]
people over yeah also like how as a lion
do you [ __ ] someone over as an [ __ ]
what if that's just I don't know man
like pushing your child off a cliff
that's a pretty big [ __ ] move like
what if what if that's just an earth
thing what if you can just evolve
intellect without being an ass soul what
if that's just something that's just
outside of our perception that's what
I'm saying man we are still the
Neanderthals in this chain thousands of
years from now we are going to be humans
that will
developers like you're just describing
like plants
they just don't do anything they don't
mind their business we need them we [ __ ]
them up have you not seen that him like
Shyamalan film [ __ ] that's what I'm
saying man we got to start cutting the
big dollars out I'm telling you like
this
maybe if we could stop feeling emotions
we wouldn't be enough we've decided that
you know a dolphin killing a child is an
[ __ ] move maybe to them they're like
what the [ __ ] is your normal Tuesday
we we decide we're putting our morals on
a [ __ ] dolphin like the dolphin gives
a [ __ ] so what you're saying is [ __ ]
are human construct yes what what we
just fight is decide as an [ __ ]
changes every [ __ ] generation that's
true that's true right like we had like
uh I don't know like yeah you could
smoke indoors before if you did that now
I think you're an [ __ ]
you could do that like 50 years ago so
we've just gotten more sense here yeah
we've just changed like what we think is
acceptable and not yes of course yeah I
mean social norms are always changing
yeah yeah you know it's no different
manner
evolving that's all that's up for
debates exactly I don't think it's fair
to say it's cut and dry yeah evolving is
not the term yeah it's like it's VR porn
Evolution or Devolution I don't know but
uh I don't know how it's like helping
the human race
technology it is definitely the
evolution in every other aspect
oh my God is there a Survivor bias with
evolution
I don't know isn't that the whole point
of evolution it is literally
survivorship but
see I don't know it I feel now it's
gotten to the point where that's not the
thing that determines
the next step in evolution like
I like could you like Okay so let's say
like like dinosaurs just got [ __ ] over
yeah like they couldn't have evolved
their way out of being struck by a
[ __ ] meteor yeah yeah at the same way
we couldn't right so like in some ways
it's like yeah survival to finish oh
with a few asterisks well the thing is
of course the humans don't turn out yeah
I've decided to destroy your home well
that's like that's like uh interesting
actually because I I think I saw like a
let me know video about like the
apocalypse and I think like the
conclusion he came up to is that it's
actually really really [ __ ] hard so
completely wipe oh yeah Wipe Out the
human rights yes yes we know this
because we're we have like [ __ ]
bunkers and [ __ ] underground yeah yeah
yeah stockpiling the only way is to
literally just blow up the Earth yeah
exactly just wipe out all of it yeah for
every you know let's say there was a you
know a nuclear bomb went off you know
not everyone who gets striked by that
dies yeah yeah exactly Will Survive it
maybe it's not the healthiest but the
people who make it through yeah no
exactly it's it's really really hard to
completely wipe off the human race yes
as it is right now we're like
cockroaches but big yeah
we're the [ __ ] virus where the virus
are we are the Cockroaches Next Level
next level of humanity is just like the
Cockroach man and terraformers that's
what we can evolve into dude
oh my God that was Evolution the
evolution dude it's like reverse Planet
of the Apes we were the Cockroaches all
along you know I think she's ahead of
point
something to think about what were we
saying before about uh yeah obviously
like and all it took was an asteroid to
like wipe out all of the dinosaurs yes
but they weren't smart enough to like
not survive out now you know they were
they once because they were too [ __ ]
big
you're literally yeah that's what that's
what that's a lot so God what you're
saying is if there's dinosaurs evolved
enough to the point where they're like
you know what there might be this thing
that falls from the sky one day and we
just all get wiped out over it so let's
build a bunker on the ground to save
ourselves I mean yeah then the dinosaurs
could have survived it's not like an
ideal Survivor you know survivorship
yeah but the point is you can you know
there is certain sects of humanity that
through millions of years can eventually
repopulate the world I'm glad there are
crazy bunker people out there yeah
because we need we need them yeah yeah I
don't want to be one I'm happy to die
when the when the asteroid comes out
yeah but aren't you then afraid that
those are the people who are going to be
the next Humanity bro if you look back a
thousand and you see people we had we
didn't have much better I think we
turned out okay I think I think I think
we'll be all right well we'll pick
ourselves back up again I'm sure
yeah did you see how World War One
started like I think uh yeah we haven't
we don't have a good track record of the
smartest people being in the best
position yeah yeah I mean uh we're doing
all right
what I've learned is that like Evolution
and survival of the Fitters doesn't get
rid of stupid people
that's what I've learned it's because if
you think about it oh no stupid people
have always been around it's just the
idea of what is considered stupid yeah
just because like let's say it's the
whole thing with politics rights my
agenda is better than yours and and it's
for them that's Survival and the way
that they want to live and that's there
so that's you know you're getting into
that now so every single person on the
internet just says like oh survival of
the food is we'll get rid of all the
dumb people and be a smarter human race
I don't think that's alpha males yeah
yeah alpha males I don't think that's
ever gonna happen
no I mean because then because then once
you get rid of all those people there's
gonna be a new type or personality or
trait of some kind that will just fill
its place again I mean our strength as
humans is that we have like everything
stupidity is a social construct someone
someone someone thought hey we should
just make something that [ __ ] flies
and can carry me it's like no one ever
that's the dumbest [ __ ] ever heard if I
was like Middle Ages I'm like [ __ ] off
oh yeah yeah we need we need crazy
people to come up with the coolest [ __ ]
yes of course I mean it's a cross
stuffed insane yeah because that's the
same they've actually made pizza cross
edible but like yeah the first person
who came up with that they were like oh
whoa whoa whoa why are the Italians not
figuring this out
let's go completely off topic well like
we need crazy people
I I like to think that stuff crossed was
invented when someone just took a pizza
and just rolled it up it was just like
it's like yeah
and it was like hang on a second I can
do that I remember I remember I had this
conversation with Joey Watts where it's
just like who do you think like invented
the first [ __ ] you know do you
remember this conversation yeah we
talked about an afterdog I'm pretty sure
did we actually I think so I think I had
the same response of like a [ __ ] sake
I'm sure people were doing it they just
didn't put a name to it you know
you know what I mean like thinking like
philosophy we didn't put a name to
philosophy I think we Googled it and it
was like the Greeks or the Romans the
Romans it was popularized it again it's
a philosophy thing all over again they
just put a name on it PornHub okay
Romans invented giving head
they were so fighthead that they decided
to give heads
you're doing okay I'm losing my mind
you're doing okay I'm losing my mind
yeah same here same here it's okay my
mind has expanded right yeah the galaxy
galaxy we are the new philosophers of
our time and that's how you know our
generation is [ __ ] if you guys are
listening oh damn it God damn it all the
hell all right well hey look at all
these patrons though they're they're
Giga brain because they're supporting
the show and letting us talk about dumb
[ __ ] I'm so sorry to all people we've
treated with this I'm sure they're gonna
be so many angles just like to all the
philosophers scientists historians
biologists yes uh scientists uh I feel
like
geneticists literally any form of field
that has some kind of uh it takes life
my apologies psychologist my apologies
to Socrates uh I didn't mean uh I didn't
mean to butcher you like that bro uh
shout out to Aristotle
but uh Hey if you like to support the
show he's the one from the Marvel film
right what Aristotle yeah
Zeus right that's the guy from uh Marvel
right yeah he's the guy with the hammer
yeah that's right that's right but hey
if you like to support the show go to
our patreon patreon.com trash days also
follow us on Twitter send us some memes
on the subreddit if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah I
hope you enjoy this shower thoughts I
hope you're listening to this in the
show we are not high by the way we are
in Japan it is illegal to procure drugs
here yes
um this is uh I don't know why we're
talking about this
we started off with haughty and end up
with dolphins and yeah I'm really glad I
brought my glasses today this was the
perfect episode for it yo thinking been
real quiet since philosophy dropped man
yeah been ripping real quiet man
everyone just stopped like they just
went they went from a door to like yeah
all right before actually before before
we end the podcast yes genuine like
math that's a weird thing to me off
right
math exists we just figured out how to
explain it as my physics teacher once
said
science makes maths its [ __ ] yeah but
like if without science think about that
would be pointing if you think about it
math is like the universal language it's
the only language there technically no
no no no no no no no no no isn't it
crazy that the Indians invented zero
okay okay
I'm actually gonna kill you guys okay
okay so
math is just like English but we just
use that to explain the things that are
happening and how they interact it's
just a language that we chose right yeah
it's a it's a human culture
yeah we it's the way that we communicate
does math exist outside of humans of
course it does yeah but like the concept
of explaining it doesn't but like the
stuff interacting and all the the the
the formulas that are happening those
things are happening whether we don't
know but like do you do you not find it
weird Okay this this is what blows my
[ __ ] mind right you know the you know
you know like a few years ago where they
changed what a kilogram is right they
mathematically change what a kilogram is
because before they had this weight that
was a kilogram it was like in a [ __ ]
bunker in France or some [ __ ] yeah and
that was a kilogram yeah and then they
changed it to be more space scientists
on equations that used a universal
constant I believe it's like a consonant
constant the plan constant
why are there constants in our law of
the universe does that know that that
[ __ ] me oh okay why is why is this why
did like the universe go yo speed of
light that's the thing now that's like
that's as fast as you can go to give you
a very easy way of kind of explaining
this all right like the difference
between Celsius and Fahrenheit they're
both communicating the same thing right
but they both they're entirely different
numbers right but one is dumb yeah
exactly you can convert right yeah and
it's the same thing if we rebuilt math
again from the ground up we could make
new constants that matched all the
formulas that we'd already made right
yes it's just the the we have decided
that for our math we're going to use
this is the constant if we changed it
the other constant we chose would have
to change right it's just we have
decided that this is how we're going to
express these these numbers and these
interactions
sorry mathematicians uh that I'm gonna
leave it there how do you invent some
some Indian one day was just like
we need a number that means nothing and
before that there was no number four
isn't that crazy
so think about it right because I'd say
numbers back then was purely for like
like trade or whatever you're using it
right so you would you would have one of
something you never had zero of
something so there's no need to have a
zero because your math wasn't using that
concept yeah but surely before okay
caveman all right you need to
communicate hey there are three X's
along there are three deers that we can
hunt surely surely that was a concept
that was needed before markets and
selling stuff existed surely yeah but
the Nintendo Falls once standing around
being like there are Zero D is to hunt
goodbye goodbye all right we're going to
continue this conversation off screen uh
we'll we'll see you guys later
[Music]